dann drehen wir wollen uns jetzt einmal
eine grafik anschauen denn paul dort ist
es am anfang gesagt es ist schwer zu
verstehen was in diesem entwurf
überhaupt drin steht und deswegen soll
das jetzt einfacher gemacht werden
erklärt uns doch mal also ist es so dass
auf initiative von vizekanzler scholz
diese grafik einmal entwickelt wurde und
man muss sagen das ist tatsächlich etwas
übersichtlicher ist als dieses große
papier wir sehen dort das ab erst
dritten das wissen wir bereits incidents
unabhängig schulen kitas friseure offen
sind ab achten dritten und auch das
tritt in kraft eben buchhandlungen
blumengeschäfte körpernah
dienstleistungen und so weiter und dann
wird spannend der dritte öffnung stritt
dann ab 8 dritter je nach institut und
da geht es um die unter 35 und 35 bis
100 da geht es um museen galerien außen
sport und so weiter und dann wird es
besonders spannend nele für dich ab dem
vierten öffnung schritt da geht es
nämlich um die außengastronomie die um
jeden fall unter 35 geöffnet werden soll
aber und das ist interessant da geht es
um die frage wie viele schnelltest
möglich sind bei 1 incidence von 35 bis
100 da soll man dann mit einem schnell
oder selbst test durchkommen können das
gilt dann auch übrigens für theater
konzerte kinos und so weiter also da
eine lockerung wenn es unter 35 ist da
braucht man kein test bei über 35 bis
100 dann schon
und das gleiche bei einem fünften
öffnungs schritt da geht es dann um
freizeitveranstaltungen und 50 maximal
teilnehmende auch dass die
unterscheidung unter 35 ohne test
darüber mit und dann eine mpk am 22
über alles weitere entscheidet also dass
ein spannender punkt den wir vielleicht
so intensive noch gar nicht gesprochen
haben dass man zumindest von der spd
seite es geschafft hat die kanzlerin
richtung schnelltests mehr zu bewegen am
anfang war davon nicht die rede und dass
man sagt in regionen eben wo es eine
höhere anzahl also ein größeres risiko
gibt da soll es schnell test geben aber
unter 35 eben gar nicht gern hier sind
auch noch mal ein paar daten eingetragen
aus dem bereich natürlich für mich
interessant für dich aber auch und
tatsächlich frühestens am 22
der tag wo wir das nächste mal hier
stehen werden für den koran gipfel das
heißt vielleicht wenn wir glück haben
dürfen wir dann mit terminen zumindest
in den außenbereichen ja das ist
natürlich da da erinnert man sich so ein
bisschen an die zeit als erstmals die
restaurants geöffnet wurden da hat
deutschland noch gar nicht über
schnelltest nachgedacht da musste man
dann auch einen termin machen man durfte
nur zu zweit oder zu dritt am tisch
sitzen also so ähnlich unkompliziert
könnte es dann wieder werden allerdings
nur in regionen wo die institute
zwischen 35 und 100 sind wollen man
sagen muss das ist die große mehrheit